quarts de finale de la coupe des
yvelines ce samedi 20 février voisins le
bretonneux leader de d1 recevait
l'équipe 2 de marly le roi qui évolue
deux divisions plus bas dès les
premières minutes de la rencontre
l'écart se fait ressentir avec cette
occasion pour les locaux quelques
minutes plus tard le voisin fc ouvre le
score 1 à 0
[Musique]
mais les visiteurs reviennent dans la
partie sur ce penalty 1 partout voisins
le bretonneux verra l'un de ses joueurs
se faire expulser avant la pause sur ce
mauvais geste
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a rapidement marqué donc on s'est mis
on s'est mis dans de bonnes conditions
derrière on s'est relâché fortement en
plus on a pris un carton rouge en fin de
première mi temps donc on s'est posé des
problèmes un peu tout seul on est dominé
en début on avait mis un 3-5-2 en place
avec une défense bae pouvoir ressortir
rapidement les ballons ça a bien
fonctionné jusqu'à comprennent le but
mais on prend un peu le but sur une
action anodine
derrière on égalise ce carrément voilà
ça va ça va carrément dans le cours du
jeu on égalise à la fin de la première
sur un penalty qui était qui était
justifiée en seconde période aucune
équipe n'arrive à faire la différence
malgré plusieurs occasions des deux
côtés
le match se finir à dix contre dix un
genre de marly le roi se fait expulser
suite un deuxième carton jaune un
partout à la fin des 90 minutes ce match
se jouera finalement tirs au but les
marly choix échoue à deux reprises
voisins le bretonneux l'emportent 4 à 2
ça fait plaisir déjà on est qualifié
pour la première fois en demi finale
donc en coupe des yvelines seniors donc
ça c'est une très belle performance
derrière le contenu on va dire que c'est
un match de coupe c'était compliqué une
équipe de marly qui n'a rien lâché on a
été bons on avait mis un plan place qui
a été respecté à la lettre par mes
joueurs on peut être déçu parce que ça
se termine aux tirs au but mais dans
l'ensemble du match on a deux divisions
d'écart avec voisin et on les a pas
senti parce qu'on a eu les meilleures
occasions on aurait pu tuer le match
avant si on avait un petit et un petit
peu plus efficace on n'a pas été c'est
penalty c'est comme ça au prochain tour
en demi-finale voisins le bretonneux
affrontera plaisir le 17 avril prochain
avec un objectif en tête remporter un
premier trophée dans cette compétition